in this capsule we will see the shape
conjunctive normal then the form
normal conjunctive it's the third
tempting ingredient of need for finally
to make proof by resolution so
what we've seen so far with
substitutions unification this is
that often only manipulated
1 predicts that the negation of a loan from
body we can have clauses or in
what we had was
predica disjunctions so to help or
but never did heroes have
for any institute then is the interest
of the normal connective form this is
to take several formulas
in a knowledge base on the
logical form of first order and of
convert it all into a syntax that
will only involve as of this Tuesday or
negation nougats that will have no
existential quantification or or
universal and that's going to allow us
to use a notion that we saw up
now
combine all of this together to make the
proof by resolution
so rather than giving a
definition of the normal form
situation I am going directly to you
list the nine steps to follow
to take a set of formula so
but I realize that we are a
set of formula in the form of a
first-rate check threatened according to its
syntax and convert it into its form
normal when nice where are we going to have to
end actually the bristles of liberals or
clauses then the first step
it's to eliminate the implication so we
is going to say the equivalent scalf implies beta
is equivalent the negation of alpha or
beta to take all the arrows
all the implications convert them
in a form or yahoo instead it's
there we would do that for the whole
all for in the knowledge base
for all of the formulas that are
find one would apply this equivalence
the second step we will reduce the
scope of the negation will use this
which we call the laws of
game to know that if I do the negation
of a formula that is the disjunction of
close to the body for example brake or f2
but it's actually they're worth it
negation of f1 is the negation of f2
same thing if I negate a
conjunction is actually the negation of
each one each of the predicates f1 f2 but
that I combine with champion so
of a or and allegations a double
negation cancel each other out so that one
gets our formula is favorite did
so that's how we do it so
that there is a negation that a negation
always be followed by a predicted rating
in my list of formulas then of oneself
I'm going to standardize the variables so
I'm going to rename the tea variables into
so that no pair of quantifies 14
who use the same variable so on
each of my lines in my base
knowledge each of the forms I
make sure they use all of them
variable names that are different
then I'll illuminate the
quantifies existential catr so for
make its effect we will replace the
variable associated with a quantification
existential by a function the
function believe as arguments the
variables that are involved in the
antilles made universal catr who
the angle so if we have for all x for
all the greeks there are aids p2 x
yz
we will replace his share for all x for
all y pi2 xy f2 xy so we replaced z
by eve 2 xy is we eliminated we have
removed
there are two helpers so we replaced
z by a function f that has as
arguments the variables that encompassed
my quantifies existential catr
electrified the two variables
it was x and y
the functions we will generate like that
when we go to mines and
existential caricatures we are going to
call functions this pass m so f
in just here it's a function of this
we love and it's important the symbol
of the function must be unique to this
formula to this line in my database
pod donwer knowledge in too much if
I use did once for a
when I eliminate a hymn reached
existential but I must have been able to use it
when I'm going to lead others quantifies
four extensions in my database
knowledge and finally if no
no argument that is to say that no
universal caricature encompassing i'm going
just use a constant so he
exists x such that q 2 x but I
would replace his part outside so
I would eliminate x and then I replaced
raul would be a constant
so in fact to be all there I will have to
use capital letters if I want
continue to use the the notation of the
team until now the standard that
I use and then at this would be a
constant that would have not been defined which
would not be used elsewhere in my
knowledge base then from his
fifth step get in shape we
calls forms take ex to say that
all quantifies universal catr I
will put them at the top of my formulas
so if I had alpha implies for all
x beta so in fact I would have more
of involvement so at the beach had
negation of alpha or for all x ben
you got I'll take the x button and then I
would put at the beginning of my formula then
I will make the distribution of
disjunctions in the conjunctions so
we want to actually put everything under a
form of conjunction of disjunction in
using the equivalence that f1 or f2 and
f3 is who goes the f1 or f2 and f1 or f3
so because if we do have a
form of a conjunction of
of dijon ctions those of that we go
eliminate caricature symbols
universal so what we do is that
if they for all x game just to remove the
for simply because we're going
eliminate the conjunctions so the in
do what we're going to do
generate separate clots if we had
paid 2 x and q2 x ben would generate two
separate lines p 2 x and q2 x whose
I will have two separate lines in my
knowledge base and then his
standard 10 and variables
so we will rename again the
variables of person who does not have two
different clauses that they themselves
variables
so we could have done that
before but the goal we took from
conjunctions and that one does not generally leave
of that clauses separate one could
to have as in the case here two clauses
different with the same variable then
there we would use long periods
separate one could add one here and then
1-2 here pay then that's the nine
steps to convert to normal form
when nice we'll look at an example
now we will apply the set of
these rules there we take the example of
Rome where we had all the formulas
following due form of logic first
rank and there we will convert them under the
normal connective form
so we will start by eliminating
the implication then here for the first
to formulate plication we have no here no
more here we are here what we will do
is that we will take the negation of the
left part of application and we see
the unirs with the right part with a
disjunction 1 or if we have none on our
apples here we have so we'll take the
negation of Roman or and we will take
then we go there we will unify it
so Pauline fillon to the combines and seen
that it's also a junction does not have
need parentheses
another application here so we're going
take negation of people x and
Greek leaders and murdered xy and so
we will take the negation of his for
combine with a disjunction at the
right part to know non loyal ex y
are we doing here I notice that of
parental therefore honor the negation of
people x and Greek leaders and
murdered ex there are parenthesis or
disloyal denial xy because of the priority
operations mark negation
applies only to the parenthesis is
finally murdered
marcus 16 hours ago there is no
of docu implications nothing to do
second step reduces the scope of the
negation not negation also for
negation also if the door is already
reduced no negation here the negation
also born here we use but its scope
already reduced to a single co-op president
here by cons we could incorporate
the negation in the parenthesis so we
gets the negation of people x or the
negation leaders y or negation of
assassinated ex y are key we notice the
sounds were converted to 10 or not
that we insert the negation in the part in
head then murdered so the eighth
formula does not change my stage to 10 the
variables then whenever a
barrier used a symbol
different parties x1 for the variable the
third formula dubbed x 2 for
ex here then ex 3 to make it a way
simple to get variables that are
different yes we have two ex 3 6x of
the 6th formula will become ex 4x of the
seventh fortune will become excellent
then will become hexis the partnership
for the 8th then we go
eliminate the quantifies catr
existential so if we do not have one in
not here
here we do not have any here
we have here so exists ex 3 and we will
replace x3 with a function of
stick apply me an argument to
the argument x2 so we introduced the
college function f1 we say a little
as the variants use f then a
figure for a town hall all of
functions of lucie college we will have
only 1 anyway so extracted
is replaced by and charges applied to x2
and at this second we have no other
when there is so much existential we go
would have to put the formulas under a
false pretense but in this case too
there is no one for all who is squeezed by
example have one for all here and then everything
what we would have done what we brought back
the port at the very beginning of the form
in that if in fact we do not have one we will
distribute the e10 junction in the
conjunctions but again here we
did not do that, that is to say we had
already in a form where we only have
so we are always if we actually
conjunctions is conjunctions
of disjunction so because it's in
do we have
no conjunctions so we have nothing to
do step 7 eliminate the quantifies 14
universal it's super simple we do
just remove them for all so if we
there are not any here we have not removed
for all etc serene for the guard
just the part if right
so we obviously do not remove only
the for everyone in dream also
of smallpox that right next it's me
gives the firefighters negation x-ore blow
Roman exceptionally one continues
like that we remove the rim x26
honorable for all x 4 if we have the for
all etc 5 for all etc. 6 and then
occur in life we ​​would have removed the
conjunctions but in what if we have some
so we did not take anything away and we would have
then to standardize the names of
variables so if we had removed some
conjunctions would have variables that
would have been present in more than one line
but in that if it's not our case
since we do not have conjunctions
remove and so we get what we have
here did everything
it's our knowledge base that we
had originally been in the form of
first-order logic we transformed
a time in a form called
normal form that we kind